I have a question for you Pedro in the
teaser trailer somebody had allowed I
love you yes yeah now I fit in and the
teaser it was coming anyway in the
teaser trailer there was they released
it many people online at first thought
that you were Justin Timberlake what was
that all about
I that's a good question I have no idea
what that was about it was great well
they didn't get a good look at you and
they thought you were Justin Timberlake
I don't know what well I felt happy
about the fact that someone would think
that a second of me is enough to be
Justin Timberlake and then I got sad
that I wasn't just until I can lose Burt
Reynolds how good are you the rope stuff
the rope stuff is absolutely incredible
yeah hard to figure out it was hard to
figure out because when someone says
everyone else gets cool weapons here's
your weapon we went to Home Depot and we
bought some rope I would think there'd
be a moment of let down and then to see
what you do with it is absolutely
incredible what I do with it yeah I'd
like to apologize to the cast and what
favorite is dead I was good with the
whip I was really good with the wig that
was my that was my forte yeah I was
strong with the whip phone with the web
[Applause]
you